so there was a very interesting article
in Fast Company recently they talked
about the fact that people who were
raised bilingual multicultural tended to
have a more fluid kind of creativity
going and the reason is because they
were familiar with multiple mind where's
right multiple cultural reality tunnels
por ejemplo de unas en Venezuela yo
hablo espanol yo tengo el acento buenas
hola no kanojo la cultura Vanessa na de
los detalles los Remos el sabor Venice
hola no yukue no OS oculto yo entiendo
mi gente para and the other side I
learned English very young I lived in
the United States you know my mother has
an American family I grew up a secular
Jew right there is that worldview there
is that mind where and having to move
between worlds allowed me to see just
how ambiguous everything is and just how
fluid everything is so that makes you I
think more open to connect the dots in
the way we're open to different
worldviews or open to the idea
reality is tightly coupled to perception
and perception is tightly coupled to our
cultural reality tunnel perception is
essentially linguistic the world is made
of language reality is kind of written
into being inside of these cultural mind
where environments in which we live and
so in order to deal with violence in
order to practice tolerance in order to
sort of fix the the maladies of the
world we first need to realize just the
fact that all of us are living in
different universes right different
cultural world views and they
understanding that and leveraging that
insight might allow us to find a way to
connect more deeply yeah
you